Này thôn rừng lòng xa lòng xa lòng xe anh bắt mình
Dương rừng lần lier pương gặm vô cùng bức xúc
Chúc cầu trẻ nâng sốt 2 mì xấu nằm bất chương có xấu rỏ
Này lại đừng chương quý cơ vi như bông bất dài thỏ
Theo phản lãnh của người dần
Nếu nâng chương xa đà bình lâu bán chờ ra ra bà chồng lâu đó
Nói ra bỏ tiền tích có cả nơi để mua xen nha
Sình sống ở bình qua hơn 2 tập kỷ
Tình dừng xuất 2 mì xấu nằm xấu qua
xấu rỏ vẫn là điều xa hội
Này lại đừng lần các chờ rồi
Ghi nhỉ như không có câu chào lời ró hạ
Điều kinh người dân đâu xó lần
Nó khi đất chương kì có xấu thì nơi lại bị bướng quý hoại
Các lần lần chương lòng trở về nếu không dài thỏ
Bó như tài xả
Công xúc mô hơn đừng quát con vi cơ mất chẳng
Chúng kinh người dân không biết phải bầu biểu hộ lâu
Để bảo vệ quý lời chính đã của mình